propriété du département des yvelines le
haras des bréviaires accueillera dans
moins de deux mois le plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre
près de mille cavaliers sont attendus
sur ce site de 55 hectares pour la 52e
édition de l'est qui rendent au maître
mot c'est de partir d'où l'on veut quand
on veut avec un principe de liberté à
travers l'itinérance à cheval à cheval
ou en attelage donc les et qui rendent
un parts des quatre coins de france et
des quatre coins d'europe voire même de
plus loin on a vu du raid et des
cavaliers japonais chinois russes pour
rejoindre un point de ralliement avec
trois jours de fête et convivialité à
partager avec les autres et qui rend
dingue pour participer à l'est qui
rendent au il faut avoir parcouru au
moins 100 km
au fil des ans cette manifestation
annuelle a permis de structurer le
tourisme équestre une activité fortement
implanté en île de france
près de cent mille cavaliers licenciés
en ile de france pour pratiquer
l'équitation mais ont pu multiplier par
le chiffre par cinq si on compte tous
les pratiquants tous ceux qui sont
amoureux du cheval et qui à un moment ou
un autre monte à poney ou à cheval
c'est la première fois que les tirants
d'eau fait étape dans les yvelines
l'occasion pour les participants de
découvrir un peu mieux le patrimoine et
le terroir yvelinois la vision
internationale que va être les qui
rendent au va nous permettre
effectivement de mettre en avant notre
territoire les yvelines et va mettre en
avant ce la partie ruralité j'insiste
vraiment sur cette identité rurale qui
est très forte au niveau du département
du 2 au 4 août le public pourra
également assister gratuitement au
spectacle et aux démonstrations
d'équitation qui auront lieu au haras
des bréviaires